[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen oder auch
mittag oder abend ich habe keine ahnung
welche tageszeit gerade das auf jeden
fall erwartet uns diese tageszeit hier
in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft und
wir befinden uns ja immer noch hier in
unserer skelett farben und die deutschen
hier sind einige dazu kommen das heißt
[Applaus]
ja ich habe hier gerade vor der aufnahme
einfach mal fünf bis zehn minuten
gewartet hier verbracht und habe mir
dann gedacht mensch die skelette sind
schon gestorben dadurch dass die einfach
herunter gefallen ja ich habe ja gesagt
dass in der heutigen folge ein bisschen
mehr action haben wir schauen was jetzt
schon alles rein kommen 34 knochen
reduziert sich fein und ein bogen wenn
benötige ich erstmal nicht allerdings
werden uns jetzt erst mal nach oben
bewegen denn ich habe ja gesagt es in
der heutigen folge ein bisschen mehr
action ist wir aber auf jeden fall ein
bisschen tagessicht draußen ist schon
mal ganz schön die sache ist allerdings
dass wir eigentlich gar nicht in den
etwa gehen müssen für das was ich für
heute geplant habe denn die strandhaus
villa ist ja immer noch nicht auf einem
aktuellen stand wo ich sie eigentlich
gerne hätte sondern sie sieht bisher so
aus das ist nur die untere etage
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht wir
arbeiten heute mal wieder so ein
bisschen an der strandhaus villa und
deswegen wollte ich auch eigentlich mit
euch heute in den neckar gehen also in
die hölle
um ein bisschen quad zu fahren wenn wir
benötigen allerdings um erstmal die
zweite etage überhaupt anfangen zu
können
die finalisierung der erste etage also
des erdgeschosses und um das
hinzukriegen müssen wir nicht in den
neckar geben das heißt heute wird auch
keine netter folge sondern die nächste
folge will wieder eine volle action
folge sein
das hier sind wir immer noch mit full
full diamant am ohr und ich würde auch
sagen dass wir nicht direkt daran
beziehungsweise kann ich euch erst mal
ganz gut zeigen was wir heute überhaupt
machen werden
denn um die wie bereits gesagt sind zwei
etage fertigstellen zu können müssen wir
erst mal die erste etage hier fertig
stellen und dafür machen wir alter wie
geil ist das denn da hinten aus
da kann ich gesehen dass das von ihr
stack aussieht wer hält hier das
fischerhäuschen hier unsere villa und
hier hinten leuchtet ist schon geil von
hier
das ist irgendwie so das projekt im
projekt für alles wir werden heute auf
jeden fall hier eine kleine feuerstelle
hinbauen dann werden wir hier unseren
esstisch errichten
wir werden das hier ein wenig an
pflanzen und begrünen nicht jeder an
einer treppe hoch ziehen und dort oben
ein paar gemälde aufhängen also das sind
die ziele für heute ich würde sagen wir
ja schon lies hier mit dem dings auf
er wird übrigens auch geschrieben luca
du kannst du einfach wasser einfüllen
dann haben wir hier einfach so ein
bisschen ja dann sieht so ein bisschen
besser aus sage ich mal und hier können
wir irgendwie nicht so einsetzen wenn
ich richtig mache allerdings haben wir
dann hier so ein bisschen wasser
zumindest also dass da auf jeden fall wo
mir die kommentare geschrieben danke
dafür mich wohl auch in die kommentare
geschrieben luca wenn du in die hölle
gehst dann öffne die die kisten in den
fraktionen nicht sondern setzt einfach
ein trichter darunter denn dadurch ist
es für die villa die dort drin leben und
uns eigentlich töten wollen nicht so als
würden mit ihren items klauen sondern
die denken dann einfach nur die jene
runter in den trichter
die sache ist ja auch allerdings ist wie
ich hier immer noch das problem haben
dass hier alles müssen zerstört das
heißt muss ich mal ganz genau wissen
reparieren und zwar habe ich uns dafür
jetzt gerade schon mal fichtenholz
treppensteigen ziegel und schienen
geholt die schiene setzt sich einfach
mal hier schnell hinter mir das auf
jeden fall wieder verbunden sind habe
ich jetzt gerade nicht mitgenommen das
habe ich jetzt vergessen allerdings
nehme ich einfach von hier vorne kurzem
blog setzte den hier vorne dran dann
habe ich hier noch fichtenholz treppen
sollten ja hier hinkommen dass sie zwar
habe ich jetzt natürlich auch nicht mit
hier vorne sollte auch keine treppe in
sondern gleich eine steinmauer
allerdings sollten die stein ziegel ja
hier hin da hat mir allerdings auch
treppen
warum seid ihr denn hier könnte man den
händler hier fragen was er so für sachen
anbietet vielleicht yahoo ab
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ob ich gerade dumm bin
wir haben doch ein herz des meeres und
das herz des meeres muss man mit achten
autos scheint umgeben so dass man aus
dem herz des meeres eine drug wiese art
vormachen kann dementsprechend werde ich
mir jetzt einfach mal 50 kilo schalen
holen das jetzt mal in den schlaf ding
table packen und dann haben wir einen
akquise hat forum mit diesem acquisa tor
kammern an die klassische web schnell
ablenken
wir reparieren erstmal schnell unseren
bahnhof also hier vorne hatten wir ja
umgedrehte schreien ziegel treppen die
fichter zeit müssen wir nicht mehr
hinsetzen allerdings hier noch eine
bruchsteinmauer und dort drauf dann
einen zaun und hier auch ein zaun dann
sieht hier vorne wieder alles so aus wie
vorher die sonne geht auch schon wieder
unter von daher würde ich sagen
wie lerne ich euch eine ganz kurze time
lab 7 1 beziehungsweise wollte ich noch
eben schnell navigator eben einmal
zumindest testen
damit soll man nämlich angeblich unter
wasser atmen können also ich setze jetzt
einfach mal hier hin
und die sieht
[Musik]
hier funktioniert gar nichts also wenn
ihr irgendwas wie kann man denn zu fett
zum atmen
ich danke dir auf jeden fall für deine
hinweise ich werde mich mal ganz gut
schlafen legen und ich leg mich glaube
ich auch auf der tier in sie bzw unser
trauminsel schlafen denn wir haben ja
dort hinten immer noch eine menge items
und unserer kiste und schaut euch auch
ein fachmann wie schön diese kirche
aussieht
ich habe hier bei nacht noch gar nicht
so richtig gesehen allerdings müssen uns
ein bisschen beeilen das nicht gleich
irgendwie monsters bonn also erstmal
ganz so erst mal ganz kurz pennen gehn
bevor irgendwelche monster kommen die
kamen nämlich gerade schon und jetzt
schauen wir mal ganz kurz herein und wir
haben hier wirklich immer noch messen
[Musik]
er sieht ziemlich teuer aus das ist
nicht so teuer aber sehr gute qualität
dafür also einmal ganz kurz hier vorne
alles mitnehmen auch das bettchen das
skelett da vorne lasse ich nicht leben
nicht dass er hier noch irgendwelche
monster abschießt und das bett habe ich
auch nur abgebaut denn wir haben ja hier
von tanktouristen haben wir noch in
betrieb war umwandeln ich glaube nicht
dass bettler sich hier stehen das ist ja
unser trauminsel bett was ich machen
wollte war hier einige gras blöcke
hinsetzen so dass das gras sie
vernünftig drüber wachsen kann die sache
ist allerdings jetzt gerade meine
behutsamkeit spitzhacke nicht mit habe
von daher eine ganz kurze time labs wie
ich das erstens mit dem weg nach vorne
machen und zweitens mir die ganzen
sachen ohne die wir für die strandvilla
benötigen
[Musik]
so freunde wir sind fertig die sonne
geht dort hinten unter das heißt ich
werde hier vorne jetzt auch mal endlich
wieder ein bettchen in unserem anfangs
häuschen platzieren und eine runde penan
denn keine monster dürfen in unser haus
hinten kommen und ich werde mir jetzt
auch mal ein bettchen mitnehmen das tut
nämlich auch ohne kommentar geschrieben
luca erst mal inspiziert abkürzen mir
wurde die kommentare geschrieben luca
warum hat es nicht einfach eine reise
bettchen mit seinem bettchen für deine
strand ausbilder das würde einiges
vereinfachen und ich möchte nicht mehr
zurück laufen ich hoffe allerdings dass
wir an diesem tage also bei dem
besonders schön aus von hier mit dem
leuchtturm und so wahnsinnig hoffe dass
wir das in diesem tage heute hinbekommen
da kann man am ende noch mal ganz kurz
in der monster fahrrad check mit viele
monster dort neu gespannt sind
beziehungsweise ist das überhaupt wenn
wir hinten sind das sieht auch neues aus
und damit diesen quatsch ich darf ich
nicht soviel ablenken lassen meine
lieben freunde ich sage ich jetzt
erstmal was wir für heute vorhaben mit
sie mir da habe ich euch das schon
gezeigt allerdings
ich zeige euch jetzt womit wir anfangen
zunächst aber immer wieder ziemlich
unser reisebett hier vorne einfach mal
dann können wir gleich schlafen falls es
einfach es ist schon echt nice aus naja
dann können wir zumindest die penan
falls es nahezu werden sollte zunächst
einmal nämlich hier die fackel weg und
hier vorne auch denn hier kommt jetzt
eine kleine beleuchtung kann die hier
auch weg und die bleiben erstmal die
packen allerdings nachher alle weg denn
wir lassen hier ist mal zwei blöcke frei
gehen dann vier blöcke nach oben mit dem
an die sie drei blöcke frei und dann
wieder drei nach oben so soll das mich
aussehen dann kommen hier auch noch an
die siebte hin und her und hin bauen wir
jetzt allerdings unseren trocken beton
wieder ab um hier net hin zu setzen
dieser weg soll allerdings brennen das
falsch da vorne soll der hellgraue
trocken beton noch bleiben allerdings
kommt der nec hier vorne hinter also
hier den kies nehmen wir mal weg dann
hier den maverick hin hier vorne mit dem
feuerzeug das ganze anzünden und dann
hier an die sieht vor
und ja auch noch an die sieht fordern
sieht das nämlich so aus ist dass unsere
kleine feuerstelle wenn wir ganz genau
gucken dass wir dadurch können dass wenn
wir nachher noch fixen nun müssen wir
allerdings erst mal unseren schwarzen
trocken beton hier vorne hin setzen
sodass er zu normalem beton wird den
müssen wir jetzt ganz gut einsammeln
hier unter wasser bot das müssen wir
echt machen dass ich irgendwo so ein
unterwasser ding machen auf jeden fall
haben wir nun unseren beton und können
diesen nun unter unseren glas tisch hier
vorne setzen also den schwarzen betont
habe ich nur zwei der bruder kurz
schwimmen gelernt also wir schauen hier
vorne auf die kante von unserem tisch
und matchen diese kante mit der mitte
von unserem gerät beziehungsweise von
der feuerstelle vorne und setzten dann
hier dreimal
beton hin da drauf kommt daneben kommt
schwarze glasscheiben und da drauf
kommen normale glas blöcken im nicht
diese hier dazwischen packen wir nun
fäden genau hier hier hier und auch hier
hier hier hin zum dass wir darauf grauen
teppich platzieren können also hier
einmal kommt darum herum du bist einer
zu viel
hier vorne auf die ecken zack und hier
dann auch zack zack zack und hier auf
die ecke und hier so dass wir hier in
der mitte glas haben und hier außenrum
teppich und das ist dann quasi unser
glas tisch daran platzieren wir nun
glatte quatsch stufen und zwar so so und
hier fordert sack und pack das hier ist
dann quasi unser esszimmertisch und nun
nehmen wir unsere glatten quartz blöcke
und setzten hier zwei neue reihen daran
werde dann allerdings auch hier vorne ab
und an 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 glas blöcke weg
nehmen denn hier kommt unsere treppe
hoch und nun startet das ganze hier
vorne dann gehen wir hier einen runter
hier ein runter hier ein runter und dann
hier genau vor dem grünen gras geht es
dann hoch und dann können wir quasi hier
vorne so hoch hüpfen und sind dann hier
auf der zweiten ebene die wir dann
hoffentlich in der nächsten folge bauen
werden von hier mit dem wirklichen baba
ausblick hier rüber hier vorne ziehen
wir dann auch noch ne band tourt das
werde ich gleich zeigen wie wir das
machen allerdings platzieren sie hier
nun erstmal bambus drei übereinander
drei übereinander zwei übereinander hier
vorne sieben gras vor und dann noch hier
vorne ein bambus hier ein bambus jeder
wiederum zwei bambus und hier noch einen
bambus und dann nehmen wir uns jetzt
auch noch eine laterne und hängen die
hier vorne dran dann haben wir nämlich
auch so ein bisschen beleuchtung in
unseren kleinen indoor garten und nun
nehmen wir unsere quartz blöcke und
markieren hier einen bereich so dass
wenn wir hier ein gemälde platzieren
dass auch wirklich einmal einen blog
bereit wird genau das gleiche machen wir
jetzt auch noch mal hier vorne und zwar
genau hier und dann auch noch zack zack
hier vorne so dass wenn wir hier ein
gemälde dann passiert es auch einmal
einen blog breit wird und wir genau
diese gemälde in einer diagonalen h
dann gehen wir hier nochmal einen block
hoch hier einen block hoch und dann ist
das nächste gemälde quasi auf dieser
höhe hier
dementsprechend müssen wir das hier auf
der seite und auch noch mal ganz kurz
hier auf der anderen seite auch noch mal
kurz
dementsprechend müssen wir das ganze
hier vorne und auch hier vorne mal ganz
kurz markieren sodass wir hier drei
gemälde haben die in einer reihenfolge
sind dann gehen wir von dem letzten
gemälde der treppe ein block hoch und 2
zur seite so dass hier das nächste
gemälde hinkommt dementsprechend dass
hier auch noch mal ganz kurz eben
absperren müssen doch auch so ein
normales hinkriegen so perfekt kriegen
wir hin bei unserem glück in minecraft
und das letzte das war kammer weil ich
gesagt habe dass ich glück habe für das
letzte gemälde grenzen wir das ganze
dann hier vorne noch mal eben kurz ab so
dass wenn wir das in die hand nehmen
hier auch zwei blöcke abstand haben und
es hier vorne hängt dementsprechend die
mit die beiden glatten krank
so sieht das ganze vorne jetzt schon mal
aus die sache ist dass wir diese wand
hier jetzt einfach auch schon mal so ein
bisschen darüber ziehen können dann seht
ihr nämlich wo die ganze reise hingehen
soll ich mache das jetzt erst mal so ein
bisschen provisorisch erfordert nur
damit ihr seht wie das ganze später
aussehen soll und dann werde ich jetzt
auch mal ganz kurze unten ins wasser
springen und den glatten quartz block 1
hat das kann finde ich bin jetzt hier an
fall hier die sonne geht die sonne geht
schon wieder unter allerdings sieht ihr
schon dass das ganze hier wirklich
anfängt zu leben also wie ich die last
die fakten jetzt nur noch kurz stehen
weiß ja nicht wie die monster hier
hinten drauf sind allerdings habe ich
dann hier vorne unseren kleinen feuer
bereich jetzt werde ich gemacht wie
haben wir unsere glas tisch mit den
glatten quad stufen wir haben hier
unseren kleinen indoor garten extrem
kreis mit unserer treppe hoch ich weiß
eigentlich müssten die blöcke dann auch
hier sei klar dass das hier alles hin
kommt allerdings passt das so nicht
richtig mit den treppen vielleicht kann
mir doch mal ein bisschen um form aber
ich bin so sieht auf jeden fall schon
mal ganz neu soll sich auch mit den
bildchen dann kann man hier so hochgehen
dann ist hier quasi die fand das geht
allerdings nach herfordern noch weiter
da kommt dann noch ein raum hin
das zeige ich euch dann alles in der
nächsten folge allerdings wird die wird
dann erstmal durchgezogen ich werde hier
den gleichen fahrzeug blog allerdings
daneben kurz entpacken
in der nächsten folge wären wir dann in
den äther gehen und hier alles weitere
versuchen fertig zu machen die obere
etage ich gehe allerdings vorher noch
mal ganz gut schlafen jedoch nicht hier
ich nehme das bett mir nehme ich einfach
mal mit und werde jetzt mal eben schon
drüber laufen denn wir haben auch eine
sache die ich heute auf jeden fall
machen wollte die auf der to-do-liste
steht und zwar ist das die aufstockung
des rasens beziehungsweise der erde
beziehungsweise des landes unter unserem
friedhof auf der trauminsel also der
tier beziehungsweise haben halt nach
oben
wenn wir das gegenüber trauminsel land
hier aber auch ich hab's vergessen ist
aber auch egal
deswegen werde ich mir hier vorne noch
mal ganz kurz aus der kiste eine menge
sand holen und auch noch eine menge erde
denn damit müssen wir da hinten jetzt
noch ein bisschen arbeiten hier vorne
kann ich den weg allerdings schon mal so
ein bisschen genauer umziehen hier so
dass wir hier vorne
[Musik]
und dann werde ich hier fordert aber mit
dem knochenmehl wieder ein bisschen auf
das gras klicken hier ist er einiges
passiert mit krippen hier haben wir
immer noch grobe erde jetzt auch nicht
warum wird das gemacht habe ich glaube
allerdings das hatte ich so ein bisschen
um den serie drumrum
naja ist auch egal und ich werde hier
vor kurzem im knochenmehl drauf machen
und hier auch nochmal und nochmal so
dass alles ein bisschen verruchte
aussieht hier auch nochmal kurz und hier
dann auch noch mal und dann fahren wir
jetzt mal eben kurz mit dem büdchen
rüber und seen direkt das hier vorne der
weg auf jeden fall auch ein bisschen
weiter wächst das sieht auf jeden fall
sehr gut aus ich weiß nicht warum das
hier nicht weiter fort wächst allerdings
geht es hier auf jeden fall schon mal
klar wir konzentrieren uns allerdings
auf den bereich dort hinten denn hier
schwebt ja der friedhof noch immer so
ein bisschen in der luft also ich hier
bei euch das kann für so ein bisschen zu
dann werde ich den dann werde ich das
ganze fichtenholz reformer kurz abbauen
so dass ich hier vorne auch noch mal
eben kurz ein bisschen erde darunter
setzen kann den setzlingen die mich auch
mal besser mit ich habe jetzt auch noch
ein paar knochen mitgenommen so dass ich
mir hier ein bisschen knochenmehl machen
kann um das ganze die auch so ein
bisschen auf den boden zu hauen und
alles ein bisschen verwüsteter zu machen
hier vorne passt ja jetzt alles ich
werde allerdings hier vorne auch noch
mal ein bisschen eher dahin setzen dann
sieht es ein bisschen natürlicher außen
das geht normal hier runter zu den
anderen höhen wo sieht auf jeden fall
schon mal deutlich besser aus und das
gleiche werden wir jetzt auch noch auf
der anderen seite eben machen hier vor
da muss natürlich erst mal auf erde
wachsen und so denn hier haben wir das
gleiche problem ja und haben wir das
noch gar nicht schön lösen können ich
werde zuallererst jedoch erstmal diesen
baum hier abfällen damit wir ein
bisschen platz haben und dann setzen wir
hier um jetzt auch ein bisschen erde auf
dieses level dann hier drunter ein
bisschen so dass wir hier auch im
perfekten übergang haben hier können wir
noch so ein bisschen zu sand wieder
rüber gehen wenn wir hier noch ein
bisschen platz im wasser und das hier
vorne das können wir theoretisch dann
aber auf der ecke hier auch so lassen
finde ich sieht jetzt auch nicht weiter
schlimm aus ersetzen mit dem eben ganz
kurz durch erde und dann haben wir das
auf der seite ja auch schon mal fertig
gekriegt hier den sitz in dem ich mir
doch mal eben mit ich werde auch das
hier unten nochmal ein bisschen
ausbessern ich weiß dass wir uns hier
wahrscheinlich nie wieder aufhalten
werden allerdings kennt ja meine
einstellung auch wenn wir das hier nicht
sehen finde ich dass es trotzdem schön
aussehen sollte knochenmehl darauf dass
sie auf jeden fall fertig das werde ich
mal kurz hinspiel habe noch nie ein huhn
aus mai bekommen
wenn ich auf das kreuz meister naja
deshalb auch eigentlich ein ganz schöner
aus beziehungsweise wenn ich den
ausblick eigentlich hinten auf unsere
will ein bisschen schöner denn wir haben
ja heute wären eigentlich fast gar
nichts geschafft an der villa sieht
ehrlich gesagt beschissen aus als vorher
weil es da unten jetzt so aussieht als
wird es brennen und rechts mit dem ich
glaube auf den tempel sah es besser aus
als wir es jetzt schlussendlich gemacht
haben allerdings werden in der nächsten
episode den neckar gehen wieder ein
bisschen action haben werden den nenner
weiter entdecken ich möchte mir auch
unbedingt in der nächsten folge ein
zweites netter portal bauen so dass wir
im netten zweites portal auf stellt
dementsprechend vielleicht auf einer
anderen seite von unserer web hier raus
kommen also kann mir dann einfach mal
gucken wo wir rauskommen und eine menge
quarz haben die zweite etage hier von
bauern also schaltet auf jeden fall
übermorgen rhein mainer dem freude 20
uhr kommt das video online tut mir leid
dass das heutige wieder ein bisschen
später kamen allerdings war ich im stau
auf der autobahn und das konnten wir
leider nicht schneller lösen ersten
daumen hoch und ein video der abonniert
main kanal und klickt auf die klagen uns
übermorgen
[Musik]